je le redis il est fondamental que les
personnes qui ne sont pas malades qui ne
correspondent pas aux critères retenus
et qui ne se sont pas vus indiquer le
port d'un masque n'aille pas chercher
des masques d'une manière ou d'une autre
parce qu'ils sont importants pour celles
et ceux qui en ont besoin
les français ne pourront pas acheter de
masse dans les pharmacies parce que ce
n'est pas nécessaire quand on n'est pas
malade j'ai compris de ce que disent les
autorités de santé que le port du masque
en population générale n'était pas à
recommander
il n'est pas recommandé d'abord parce
que l'utilité du port du masque en
population générale
autrement dit lorsqu'on se promène dans
la rue lorsque on respecte les gestes
barrière lorsqu'on respecte les
distances de sécurité
il n'est pas recommandé car il est
inutile et qu'il prive ceux qui ont
besoin des masques
ces masques ffp2 ou chirurgicaux ils
sont réservés aux soignants et nous
devons avant tout sécuriser notre
capacité à leur donner
à mesure que nous montrons j'espère que
nous pourrons l'élargir mais nous avons
d'autres catégories de masques
différents qui sont homologués 85
prototypes ont été validés durant les
derniers jours il n'y a aucune décision
de recommandations de port du masque ni
obligatoire ni recommandé en tout cas à
ce stade pour la population générale
nous déploierons ensuite tous les moyens
nécessaires à la protection de la
population
en complément des gestes barrières que
vous connaissez bien et qu'il vous
faudra continuer à appliquer l'état à
partir du 11 mai en lien avec les maires
devra permettre à chaque français de se
procurer un masque grand public mais il
est certain que les trois semaines à
venir seront difficiles et que nous
devons rester vigilants
le port du masque sera rendue
obligatoire dans tous les transports
mettra ou comme bus et les opérateurs
devront au moins pour les trois semaines
à venir
s'organiser pour permettre même dans le
métro de respecter les gestes barrière
en aucun cas le fait de ne pas
recommander le port du masque en
population générale n'était au moment où
nous l'avons fait lié au fait que nous
manquions de masquer ce n'était pas la
raison la raison elle était encore une
fois scientifique et j'invite les
français qui s'interrogent à regarder
les recommandations scientifiques au
mois de février au mois de mars avant
que l'académie de l'académie de médecine
a fait trois semaines qu'elle recommande
le port du masque
lorsque nous avons dit que nous étions
en difficulté pour approvisionner comme
nous le souhaitions tous les soignants
nous étions au mois de février donc il
faut pas confondre les deux choses